effectivement arrêt habitants est pas
hyper bien en ce moment ce qui a une
réunion une pré réunion du film comme se
fait traditionnellement
quand un film est fini qu'il va bientôt
sortir donc les acteurs ont été ont été
réunis par la production et tout le
monde a été invité sauf ary abittan qui
était totalement
blacklisté de l'événement et selon nos
informations effectivement c'est quelque
chose qu'il a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
et c'est peu de le dire affectés donc
voila c
[Rires]
est donc oui donc non mais c'est vrai
alors vous comprenez que valérie non
mais je comprends évidemment que nuit
peut-être été peiné de la chose mais
c'est normal qu'ils se réunissent sans
lui en se disant voilà on a on a un
souci de toute façon harry habitants
qu'ils soient déclarés coupables qu'ils
soient déclarés innocents il pèse sur le
film au moment de la sortie oui mais là
ça c'est pas et vont traîner et donc
même la réunion avant se disant comment
est-ce qu'on va gérer la promo c'est
normal qu'on la fasse en disant comment
on va faire que cette vague un événement
convivial où tout le monde voilà et
autour d'un dîner territoire n'aurait
pas de quoi tu penses tu pas il est il
attendait à moosch pas là pour voilà
mais il est il attendait certainement
que les gens avaient été admis le
soutiennent un peu plus
là maintenant sa carrière artistique est
directement impacté ses one man show
sont supprimées il est boycotté pour la
promotion moi je trouve ça normal c'est
impossible autrement d'autre part il est
aussi perturbé parce que dans la
procédure il ya des actes judiciaires
qui se multiplient plaignantes a été
entendue il est donc du coup c'est vrai
que il est inaudible ary abittan idée on
va faire de la promo aurait entendu il
ya quelques jours et ary abittan sera
entendu lui en janvier il aurait été
énormément blessée par cette décision il
devrait aussi ne pas participer à la
promo du film donc maintenant attendus
que les chaînes qui ne veulent pas
l'inviter les émissions une décision qui
a été prise avec le staff
c'est vrai que ça peut tant que l'
affaire n'est pas voilà fini et que l'
enquête n'est pas finie qui n'est pas
déclaré innocent
qui vient vous ne posez pas de questions
aime ça
mais je veux dire ça possible la
maîtresse
accélère bien c'est un soutien bien pour
lui qu'il soit innocent ou coupable
vraiment le retrait pour lui pour sa
santé mentale c'est bien qu'ils se qui
se repose un petit peu effectivement
n'importe quel plateau ça serait bon
alors on parle à une seconde du film et
puis la deuxième question bien sûr c'est
le violent face et c'est horrible oui
c'est vrai qu'un possible ob guillaume
sur un pull et pas censurer dix films il
est juste mis à l'écart le temps de la
première ça normal et puis qu'est ce
qu'on a fait au bon dieu c'est un succès
populaire c'est une comédie familiale
donc je comprends que les producteurs
des réalisateurs les acteurs du film
n'ai pas envie d'être mêlé à quelqu'un
qui est accusé de viol et agace mais
regardez ce qu'ils sont forts est-ce
qu'ils ont peur pour le le succès du
film
we are est préjudiciable à la paix non
mais j'ai du ciel et puis vraiment une
gestion crise ou voilà tout le monde
s'est réuni pour savoir qu'est ce qu'on
fait et puis pas dans les décisions
c'est à réacteur n'est pas invitée au
petit repas traditionnel où tout le
monde tout le monde tous les acteurs se
réunissent
tous on est étonné il s'en étonner façon
là il est au fond du trou il a été
pendant plusieurs plusieurs jours chez
un ami en province il a décidé de la de
changer il vivait dans un appartement
parisien il y retournait que le week-end
dernier pour prendre quelques affaires
et la loi notre appartement à la en ce
moment harry habitants et pas au top de
sa faveur c'est normal